this one might be a bit harder to
navigate than I thought
we're organizing the rappers gangsters
everywhere gangster
damn I lied Amin push on one they're
scared of the big white guy these guys
are quite entrepreneurial
India
also the Chucho we've all wanted to toe
today we are looking for robbers oh yeah
da ba da da moneh hasta maana a co-pilot
and this is not your normal search for
robbers we're in Karachi Pakistan going
to the neighborhood of the ADI and Leo
day was the most dangerous neighborhood
in Karachi the fifth most dangerous city
in the world five years ago I've heard
things have cleaned up quite a bit and
part of the city part of the
neighborhood coming through has been
this rat culture and a lot of the people
young people have gotten into rap and so
we're gonna find these guys
[Music]
fuel stop I can say this place feels
hectic
and like I'm
smashed in the middle of something
massive and there's no way out
[Music]
you guys I don't know about this mission
it's quite hard corn here
heavy vibe for sure
and I don't see how there could be a rap
scene
mixed in this place I'm gonna give it a
go but I'm not gonna be dumb I'm gonna
be done with it
feels dicey I'm gonna pounce
it feels the fish I seem to be honest
like there's the safety of the in the
rickshaw like feels comfortable being in
but once I'm out there with a GoPro my
face speaking English it's a different
world
[Music]
Salam alaikum
hey guys
this one might be a bit harder to
navigate than I thought
I'm in yachting
Salam alaikum it's not Lyari
right this is Lyari do you know where
the you know where the rappers are
import the rapper's the music this area
and norm you do notice coconut milk as
you know no no the rappers such as eg to
the rap music God some oranges a gun
quite a crowd going here
and got some oranges for you guys thank
you
is an orange
you guys want an orange so this
neighborhood five six years ago is very
dangerous right yeah how is it now she
got the Rangers yeah
don't shoot the Ranger boys before our
five six years ago what was it like was
it you couldn't walk around here or what
watch it all much
I'll tell the people don't want to come
here because the ordinary
okay uh sir the Chucho you don't want to
teach Oh
the left
Agito there is no families in the area
to danger so it was the most dangerous
neighborhood in Karachi right yes
yeah yeah so the Rangers came in yeah
then they fixed it in like a very short
time right yes amazing me that this is
you yourself and your brothers are all
right I got really lucky stopped at an
intersection where they're Rangers which
are the security forces these guys came
up we had a huge pack of people guide in
my left here is a boxer his friend is a
rapper so we're waiting for the
transport to come and then we're gonna
go see what's going on with a rap scene
here right okay
what an experience coming in to Karachi
today I came in this morning thank you
the ball came right to here this is all
I've seen a project do I want to go with
him yeah he knows the robbers you know
the rappers
let's do this let's do this
okay
[Music]
but it's working out
Gai have a guy
to the rap scene
[Music]
what so this rappers not here he's out
in the country so this this is the most
famous rapper
[Music]
thank you for your help all the people
come outside
I will also help with them you help
anyone that comes to neighborhood yeah
you guys are so cool
- outside uh-huh I know anything I don't
know anything about there
over there they
also they follow or also giving them
they will help you even honky yes
what goes around comes around yes other
countries like other side like yeah we
help each other yes
the kids are excited not excited more
it's more like scared they're scared of
the big white guy you guys are right
[Music]
there we go warming you up Oh buddy what
the the main rapper is not here the
other rapper right his friend came out
and they're getting another rap where I
guess right so we're gonna have a couple
rappers we just had a meeting in there
and a blue player we're organizing the
rappers one-hour right
coming back to the hood I'm gonna do it
on the street I think it's a great setup
for the rap video
going back to the Rangers kill roughly
an hour
five six years ago what was it like what
was the feeling like in this
neighborhood I feel like very
uncomfortable because because our not
self that time gang wars game was a
gangster gangster Serbian gangsters we
shoot them with all the body but now no
gangsters here know that time not dance
with only one gangster the boxers
[Music]
what are you gonna do like this
oh you know what you're doing I don't
you could probably beat me up
thank you easily it's all technique
right yeah you got that I don't do you
come with me - okay okay let's go to the
roof
[Music]
Wow
Gilmore nice up so this is your this is
your building yeah yeah this is your
building wow these guys are quite
entrepreneurial he owns this whole
building they're building out apartments
al-'ardi
there we go here's Karachi big sprawling
monster beast in the city this place is
a machine if it's got a tooth or
anything
okay the tallest building
the see is out there this is not
chipboard right and so how many
apartments does your building have its
biggest Empire the five point five five
five doors when I lower doors and three
up I have any floor one one place every
four is one flower one yes so it's
pretty big Danny big very big
that's the cow market over there right
garbage okay this construction is also
mine their construction behind the mask
Oh Jane dear so you guys are big mana
you guys are breaking ground he is the
father LM normal mother's not for
motorbike yes is what guys simply be
crushing it
can you get for rentier apartment how
much to rent
how much today 35,000 in dollars 167 167
dollars yes for the through the
apartment does it come with furniture no
they don't have any furnish around to
out to the rappers Nasser a relative of
a relative picked us up bring us back
out to luminance and I'm Z you ready
okay here we have Ramsey Ramsey is
obviously a rapper yeah and we're gonna
start this rap in the alleyway then work
out to the street go in there okay
so a lot of the rappers are out of town
right now obviously this was a
last-minute spontaneous thing so they
weren't organized
[Applause]
by 17 million 70 million
Wow we ready guys yeah we ready here we
have ramsey Romsey Abbey Shaka guys
let's do this yeah yeah yeah yeah funny
movie so be but our
let's do this okay yeah very nice
ha-cha-cha
there you have it guys I'll be shut up
rap in
formerly most dangerous neighborhood in
Karachi
but no longer full of cold people yeah
very nice hospitable beautiful people
and the rap is the outlet so I've been
told
away from the crime so what an adventure
today was no no okay do not point the
camera anywhere near ladies thank you
for setting that up that was very cool
very cool
all right guys okay not a good day 1
Karachi
tomorrow is SHINee another adventure
driving me back some hotel get it
beautiful job Eden such beautiful
hospitality
come on very humbling very humbling
place yeah I just came in here a couple
hours ago and all of a sudden I have all
these friends and beautiful people
around me so thank you brother that you
will tell us okay thank you guys what's
your stance and everybody because I jog
these mob up you guys are so kind thank
you thank you so much thank you
I'm not so man you really saved me over
here